news i'm lana nguyen i'm a finance
reporter here
in new york and i am talking to killer
mike
aka michael render nice to me nice to
have you here michael thank you
hey luanne how you doing i'm great thank
you so
today we are talking about black owned
banks mike and i have been talking about
this for a couple of months now
and uh he's finally found time in his
busy schedule promoting his album and
promoting his new venture greenwood um
to talk to us
and so i just wanted to open the
conversation mike to discuss
hashtag bank black what is this movement
and why did you start supporting it
several years ago well let me let me
first establish i've banked black my
whole life i didn't have a choice
betty and willie who were my
grandparents uh marched me and my
sisters down to
a black bank when we were children and
we all got accounts and
they had done that as young people and
their parents had also done that
um so i'm from a tradition over a
hundred year tradition
of banking black and um i want to tell
people that bank black is not
exclusionary and greenwood is not
exclusionary
it is created to circumvent some
problems that
worker-class people no matter what color
have big banks are pulling out of
working class in
in poor communities to be frank many of
those communities
disenfranchised housed black and brown
people
in their place came predatory lenders i
mean predatory
um people who cash checks like check
cash in places liquor sorts things that
nature
where they were being charged 20 25
cents on a dollar cash check
this gives them a card that is
essentially
not taking money from them every time
they use it it gives them the ability to
bank
fully in there um to do their banking
fully from their phones which gives them
a freedom
that the brick and mortar banks having
left and robbed them up
so the back the bank black movement is
the first step in the american dream and
the
first step is to be able to do simple
things like buy a home and a car
make sure you have a savings make sure
you have something to save for
retirement
it helps working-class people work their
way and matriculate their way up the
ladder
it helps working-class people do things
like buy a first home
to make sure that they have something to
leave their children and they have
something
that's um that is accrued that it's
worth something that that establishes
well
um everybody's not going to be a
millionaire a zillionaire billionaire
but that does not mean that people
cannot have dignity and being a part of
the working class and middle class in
this country
and banking black allows black people a
disenfranchised community
that had been denied through terrible
acts such as slavery jim crowism
redlining and now brick and mortar banks
being pulled out
um they have just been terribly treated
and i think that this does a lot
to restore the ability to achieve the
american dream to have some sense of
equity and equality
and to not only service the black
community but when the black community
is stronger financially
the greater community is stronger
financially because in capitalism
competition ends up helping the consumer
more than anyone else
great and you know we've talked about
black owned banks extensively and you're
always shouting out different firms you
even did that when we were preparing for
this call just now right so
you talk about black owned banks a lot
now that you're kind of coming into the
scene with your own digital bank
um how does that affect you know what
you say about this movement now your
competitor you know how has that been
received
well there's no shortage of churches
liquor stores and barber shops in my
community
so you could never get enough haircuts
jesus or whiskey
and i think that i think that banking
can work the same way
i think that we are new that we are um
of course you want to be the biggest
baddest business on the block and i
think we're going to grow to be there
with that said i believe that um most
working class people
so if you're poor it might be a little
harder you've got one bank account then
you're saving under the mattress like i
still do
and i get that but if you have an extra
bank account to save toward christmas
if you have a bank account to set up for
your babies i encourage you to set it up
at any black bank whether it's carver
whether it's one united whether citizens
trust
whether it's any of those banks i
encourage you to do it because we need
to be taking care of our own community
without the bank of italy that was
started by italian immigrants who were
coming through
from ellis island to make sure they had
the ability to lend to
start businesses we would never have
bank of america which it grew into
so if we don't support black banks we're
not going to find it easy to find
support in the banking space
but i'd like to add that there's a new
dog on the block man and she's walking
around
trying to be seen and that is greenwood
we have the ability
to create a lot of noise to focus that
black dollar and the ability to
facilitate
fairness in the banking institution so
we want to add to the legacy of black
banks not necessarily take away
i don't want to see another black bank
disappear what i'd like to see is
cooperation collaboration and a bigger
conglomeration
and i think that time will tell them
we'll see what happens and we were
talking about the partnership that you
are
right now negotiating with you know a
partner bank
that can't be named yet but i want to
ask you about
these big main street banks if you do
end up partnering with a big
firm how do you make sure that they
ensure the mission of
greenwood is carried through that racial
justice and equality
are something that's going to be upheld
by that bank as opposed to maybe
perpetuated
um you know or inequality being
perpetuated i like to go back to a story
where
wells fargo as we know their their uh
their ceo just got into a little trouble
saying he couldn't find black talent um
i'd like to push back and challenge to
say that i believe black talon's out
there and if it's not
what are we going to do to be like a
sports franchise and develop the black
talent so
where he sees a lack of black talent i'd
like to encourage him to partner with at
least three schools in the metropolitan
atlanta area start with kindergarten
um and mentor those kids through 13
years of school and get those kids into
college and graduate without what you
want to see
much like baseball invest in the
caribbean to grow talent much like the
nba
investing in the cities in uh united
states i think that you should be
investing in talent and i think there's
talent out there
beyond that though i think that there is
a real will and want to learn what is
the right thing to do in this moment
and there is a sincere effort to partner
and have true collaborative partnerships
where you're listening to the partner
who may not have the biggest person who
may have the
most experience in this direct contact
with that community so i think that
right now corporations want to learn
because they not only realize
that it's wrong morally or wrong
philosophically
i think that they understand it's bad
for business to have black people out of
the financial loop
in this country so i think that whatever
partner we choose to go with
is going to become a better corporation
for having partnered to us and it's
going to give us a wider
spread you know i think if we're all
doing a little bit no one will have to
do a lot
but i think a lot needs to be done to
make up for a lot of the things that
were done in the past
and mike um so in episode one of trigger
warning you tried to spend all your
money at black owned businesses
and you really struggled right so my
question for you is how do you avoid
that
now that you're opening a bank that you
know is aimed towards
black and and latinx people how do you
make sure that you aren't you know kind
of being too narrow in your focus
well we're not because you know the
beautiful thing about this country is
it's for everyone
you know i i i do business with every
type of nationality person
whether it's barbering or the restaurant
business or real estate business
i'm a few different businesses and i see
all types of people
i encourage people whether it's in my
music or my daily talks
to make sure that you have a friend an
ally or someone in your life that's not
from your racial ethnic background
that is not a bisexual persuasion does
not if your own spiritual belief because
honestly
that's the only thing that makes
collaboration of cooperation work so
effectively in this country when it does
so
i believe that in the same way you know
i believe there are three
three ways i define black businesses
you're owned by black people
totally ran by black people or you're
owned by people other than black but to
employ black people which is probably
for the community or if you're a small
business that cannot
be um higher or being owned by black
people that you do
my community fairly i think that we have
the ability to do that in terms of
cooperation and collaboration
and i think that we're going to do it
okay and then just a final question and
again this is a big picture question
how has the banking industry contributed
to inequality
racial inequality in the us and what
does greenwood want to do about that
redlining we know was um we know that it
was damn near possible in cities like
chicago
for black people to get some of the sun
the same loans that they deserve
we know the gi bill um was not honored
when black soldiers came home from world
war
ii we know that where you have
comparable um
comparable people applying for loans
that white people get turned down an
eight percent rate black people are
turned out at a 21
rate i know that their businesses with
nuances that people don't understand
like
when you're talking about getting a
small business loan for a barber shop it
could be much more hard at a larger bank
because they don't even understand black
guys go get their hair cut
four times a month they have to go every
week 25 a week is 100
a month you know that's about 1200 a
year they don't get that concept because
their customers go to get a haircut
every three months you understand so
there's there's a need for for this
there i think that there
is a tradition of not helping the black
community
um in all institutions not just banking
institutions
we've been failed by the medical
institutions we've been failed by the
political machines
um we've been failed by virtually at the
education institution
but i think that banking can understand
even faster than some of the other
institutions
that the black dollar is a powerful
force in this economy
and if we help the black community get
financially literate and properly focus
at black dollar to grow business
to further help competition in this
country that the
banking systems wins greater society
wins the black community wins
and overall the customer wins okay mike
i gotta ask one question for the fans uh
you're you're
parlaying your business skills into
finance right now but uh what does that
mean for your music career
i'm gonna keep singing and dance until
the day i die i love my first job and my
wife
who's a far more brilliant businessman
than that reminds me that ultimately
michael i'll handle the numbers you just
keep singing and dancing
great okay thank you very much killer
mike michael render
appreciate your time today i appreciate
you a lot of respect have a great day